for more uh boris is going to explain
the second half to
get into the
the real map of the talk i don't know
it sounds like that
okay so i think
i got the
the general philosophy out of
the system and uh let's actually uh um
try to understand understand something
about the rate of adaptation so first
addressing
oscar's
example of
adaptive
mutations in asexual population okay so
uh
okay we're talking about population with
fitness diversity so let's refer to
this
fitness
access
um
let's label it x and generally refer to
a fitness differential relative to the
mean in the population and now we have
our little bin
distribution and very often we want to
describe this simply uh by continuous
function approximation we'll take this
continuum limit
and
the simplest thing is
just to write down all mean fieldish
type equation for
dynamics of this distribution so
clearly
individuals that are
better than mean
in fitness
uh grow exponentially with the rate
given by this
differential and this is a very simple
little equation basically tells us
that the number of individuals above the
mean is going to go up the number below
the mean is going to go down and the
whole thing is going to translate
to the right
with
some velocity where this velocity is
basically the rate
of increase in this case of the mean
fitness and this is simple enough you
easily solve this and demonstrate that
the solution is simply the gaussian
where the mean translating forward with
a constant speed equal to
the variance in this distribution
and right the rate of adaptation
proportional to the variance is
fischer's fundamental theorem
so the only thing is
the fischer fundamental theorem is
correct
the only thing is it actually doesn't
tell us anything about how much variance
there is in
in this uh distribution so in fact it's
not just one solution so we have this
traveling wave solution but it's not
just one solution it's a whole family of
solutions which have different width and
move with different speeds
and
and of course
this can't really be true in any finite
population because
with what we have here right now in the
finite population
even if we uh
model this by continuous distribution we
know that we have sampled it only to a
given depth and there is
maximum fitness in any finite population
right so for a gaussian
we know
okay for gaussian with and samples we
know exactly
what the expected value for this maximal
fitness
is in the sample and
it is uh
only logarithmically or square root of a
logarithmically dependent on the
population size and uh
there'll be lots of uh
logarithms of population size in this
talk and pretty much all of them
uh
and one another way related to
uh this fact so relation between
so the width of a distribution and
its leading edge
so uh
okay why is this important
uh
right
fissure traveling wave moves forward
because uh
um so the imaginary individual way ahead
of uh
of the front will eventually gets a
chance to get amplified and take over
the whole population
but if there isn't such an individual
there is no mechanism of producing it
right so in the finite population this
fischer wave will basically slam into
its leading edge the variance will
collapse and it will stop so to really
calculate
what the variance in the distribution is
and what the velocity is we have to
so start thinking about how the leading
edge here is going to move forward and
there are
two effects which are going to do this
there is some probability of a mutation
occurring somewhere
some individual in this distribution and
advancing it from point x prime to to x
so this is just a parametrization of
mutation effect distribution right so
general that virtually says nothing
and the second effect
uh
which we will
uh talk about in a moment is uh
recombination so actually in the asexual
in the sexual population
uh right
two individuals from the population will
come together and make a baby at uh the
fitness
um
with the fitness
uh related to
ancestral fitness but not the same
we said these are so general they say
almost nothing but it's not quite right
i mean they say that these these kernels
only depend on the individual's fitness
yeah so you know
uh
yeah this definitely says something
so
okay so let's uh
talk about uh
um
well
uh oscar's
model here which was uh
worked out by michael desai and danielle
fisher daniel and told was here
yesterday
well anyway so
let's uh for simplicity say that they're
only beneficial mutations and they all
have characteristic size so that
basically means that the mutation
falling in a given bin can
move the offspring
one bin to the right
and
so new
fitness territory will basically be
colonized by mutated offspring
of the nose of individuals in the nose
of this distribution in the top bin
that maximal fitness again
right and
in order to
calculate
the rate of adaptation
well what we have to do is the following
mutation rate times population size
that's the rate of
mutational influx into the population
each mutation carries benefit s
so
and but then the all important factor is
what is the probability of fixation
which of these mutations that occurring
everywhere in this distribution have a
chance of fixating and
and taking over and uh
the insight of these two gentlemen was
to realize that it's basically just the
top bin mutations that the mutations
falling into the top bin that have a
chance to fixate and
the offspring
of the vast majority of this population
are basically never going to make it so
genotypes typical genotype is basically
doomed for
extinction right and it's the rare
genotypes
in the nose of the distribution that are
going to take over the future
so
very crudely
what i just said is a statement that
only the fraction of all mutations the
ones that fall into this uh top bin
right number of individuals in the nose
over the total population right that's
the fraction only they will
have a chance
at
passing on their
genes
and
then in addition not all of those either
since
we talked about stochastic extinction
and
survival
probability
in the face of
the drift which we said was proportional
to the fitness advantage that's the
difference between the nose here and
and the mean
and now
you observe
that
this big n factor actually drops out the
only thing that's important is
how big is uh
is
the nose
and uh the whole wave is moving forward
and
the stop bin exists only transiently
right until the new mutation comes in
and seeds yet another another bin right
and
so it is growing exponentially
for a time
such
that mutation rate
times
the size
of of this bin is equal to one
so anyway
i don't think i really want to walk you
through the arithmetic here
but uh
all i want to impress you with is
the notion that
it's a calculation but
it's not a terribly deep and profound
one
and you can do it at home and
especially with the
decision paper in hand
and
it just illustrates
this very simple idea
that
the most important thing in
understanding
the rate of adaptation
is to understand the probability of
survival for a new allele
and that very much expresses
the underlying dynamics of clonal
competition there are all these many
clones that are generated by mutations
in different backgrounds and they're all
competing
but only small fraction of them
are going to survive
and
now if you actually work out what
you know this arithmetic tells you
you will find okay with my simplified
arithmetic here so
i think there are there are some experts
in the audience who are going to
immediately correct me that this is not
quite the right result
but all i want to show you here is that
a linear dependence is replaced by a
logarithmic much weaker dependence on
the population size
and
the real expression
you'll find in
this eye fischer
but
the guts of the calculation uh we
captured in uh just three lines on the
previous
previous side
slide
okay
so
i obviously plan to do this in my
first
lecture
and now we're going to start talking
about
the role of
recombination
and uh
um
and the importance of uh
interactions so we just talked about the
uh one particular kind of
an interaction so that was interaction
between different clones in an asexual
population as they compete against each
other so suppose this in population
and
this bunch of beads is a genotype
and uh in red
is genetic variants and
there could be
many individuals that are genetically
identical
especially right in an asexual
population that will happen so these
form a clone and then different clones
this clone a competes against clone b so
we've
just discussed this in great detail but
the other important interactions here so
uh
there are many alleles that contribute
to the fitness of of the clone and you
may
be interested as you know we're just
talking about
the
probability of fixation
for a given mutant allele right
so
the probability of fixation for a given
allele depends on which genotype
it lives on
right so
and this allele alpha for example
sometimes will be coupled to the fate of
allele beta sometimes it will be coupled
to
the fate of
some
other allele
and even a deleterious mutation
can rise to prominence in the population
if it is riding on the back back of
beneficial mutations so that that's
called genetic hitchhiking
so otherwise known as genetic draft so
we were talking before about the genetic
drift so this is just a sort of
non-heritable stochastic variation in
offspring survival
right
but
this
hitchhiking
contributes another element of
stochasticity into propagation of the
allele right so now it depends on which
background
this allele arised on
and
once we turn on recombination
of course
this allele will be able to hop from one
background to another
so
the effect
of genomic background on the propagation
of that allele from the point of view of
the allele will look like uh so the
stochastic force
so
uh sometimes
uh so a good background will help the
spreading of the allele bad background
will hurt the spreading of the allele
and
and in fact in a genetically diverse
population
the effect of
the so-called genetic draft
dominates the stochastic effect of drift
so that's another kind of interaction we
want to talk about and
the third one of course is the very fact
that the
phenotypic contribution
of
any pair of alleles
is not necessarily equal to the sum
of their individual contributions right
so that's known as trade as epistasis
and uh of course yeah
why do you separate them into
hitchhiking and clonal interference it
seems to me like hitchhiking is an
example of
full interference it might make more
sense to separate them into interference
because they occur on the same
background and interference because they
occur on different backgrounds and
compete with each other but it doesn't
really matter if they're beneficial or
neutral
um
i don't really want to
enter
a
debate over
my use of words on my time
so let's do this after
this clock stops ticking
um
okay
okay these the effect of
these interactions strongly depends on
the rate of recombination right so for
example
clearly clonal interference competition
between
different clones or at least the outcome
of it
strongly depends on
so the possibility
of
recombination to bring these two
different alleles put them on the same
genotype and
perhaps build a better genotype if those
two
were
beneficial right on the other hand
this effect of hitchhiking or background
selection
so the fact that uh
the deleterious
allele may be hot maybe hiding behind
the beneficial allele sitting on the
same
genome
is also
ameliorated by recombination right
because the recombination event will
set these two alleles asunder and
now all the deleterious
effects of our allele
beta
will be seen
by natural selection
and
recombination therefore will increase if
you like the effectiveness of uh
natural selection acting on individual
alleles so this is a distinction between
natural selection acting on genotypes
right uh
and uh in an asexual
population that's sort of all there is
there is
the whole genome
of an individual right
and uh the sexually reproducing
population
which is really
uh at least in some
limit can be thought of as a soup of
alleles
that are being uh
sort of continuously reshuffled
and transiently put together
on
just one
genome
and one
individual
and
if you like get tested by natural
selection in one particular
combinatorial reassortment
so
let's first
think about
what sex and recombination will do
to the rate of
adaptation
in this
large rapidly mutating populations
where selection is confounded by
a clonal competition
okay so suppose the new mutation comes
in
and falls uh happens to be an individual
which is uh much better
than the mean in in the population
well so
um
carriers
of that mutation are going to expand
they're going to proliferate in the
population so
now i guess my time is going this way
and the width here represents a fraction
of the population carrying that new
mutant allele
so
it is rising
the only problem is
that mutation rate is high population is
large so other genomes are also getting
beneficial mutations everybody is
getting better
and now suddenly
our particular
clone
carrying a given mutation
finds itself
worse than average and now starts
shrinking
right at this stage is basically doomed
for extinction
except
perhaps with a little bit of luck
one of the offspring
recombines
with a better genome and transfers
this mutant allele that we're tracking
onto a better background
and
now this process starts again
so now basically think of a given allele
surfing on this evolutionary traveling
wave and
the trick is
for the allele
to maintain presence
at the leading edge
long enough
so that
it can actually expand and fixate in the
whole population
so you ignore the sort of surfing effect
due to mutations not due to combination
so just having a mutation that brings
you up to the next higher fitness yeah
no i don't want to ignore anything
right so if you like uh
uh you can recast this whole uh
um decide fischer story exactly in the
same language and in fact the
calculation is going to be pretty much
the same i mean arithmetic is a little
different the result is a little
different
but logic is very much the same so
let's go over this again so we got the
population we got a new mutation
um
starting
a clone on the background x
and
then
many of its offspring
are going to recombine onto different
backgrounds and some of them
will
will be will be worse off than they
started on and some of them will be
better off
and
one way i can redraw this picture is
sort of
not even trying to represent the size of
the clone so the number of individuals
with that genome
but uh
just keep track of their fitness right
so each little bubble here will turn
into a stick
and time goes this way so this is where
this clone first came into existence and
that's where it got extinct
i guess this was our first clone
and before it got extinct it seeded a
few new clones
and then those clones seeded a few new
clones
and so on and so forth
and this of course is happening
alongside with
this adaptive shift in the whole
population which we know how to describe
as a fischer traveling wave of course
this fischer traveling wave is a very
mean field description which really pays
no heed to fluctuations
whereas
my picture here
is really trying to
zoom in on
the fluctuations
and
but the bottom line is
these two pictures
have to agree with each other
because this population ultimately
is just a superposition of all the
little clones that
are jumping back and forth
right
so
what we need is a way
of
arriving at the
self-consistent description of the
dynamics in terms of this very
stochastic
process involving individual clones
and so the mean field
description of the whole population in
terms of fischer's
traveling wave
and
and it is exactly this uh effort to
self-consist the two pictures
that uh
will fix
um the variance in a distribution right
that fundamental
theorem of uh
uh fissure
by itself
cannot do for us
let me
redraw this picture in terms of a
numerical simulation which you can
easily do right and
so
still the same sort of stick
diagram
and
these little sticks are individual
clones
and
every so often you see a new clone
way ahead of the rest of the population
at that time appears
and actually the color coded here
is the size of the clone
so
it grows very large it has lots of
offspring they colonize
um
many genetic backgrounds
and uh prosper for a while
but uh eventually nevertheless go
extinct
right
and then every so often so there is some
probability that in this process
the offspring of a given allele will
colonize
the whole distribution right we'll go to
fixation now our job is actually to
calculate
the
non-extinction probability right the
probability to succeed
rather than fail
and then we're going to use exactly the
same general
philosophy the total mutational flux
into the system times the survival
probability
will determine
the
rate of evolution i mean rate of
adaptation and the width of a
distribution
so
now let's actually try to calculate
so we have this little bubble
and the first task
while there are very few
copies of this allele
for this allele is not to become extinct
right
let's calculate the extinction
probability right so with probability
almost 1
it will become extinct right away and
that's the end of the story
but
with the probability
1 minus this extinction probability
which is to say x over one plus x
it will not become extinct right away
and will grow
into a large clone
and then
it will
have an opportunity to recombine
and start
new clones
on different backgrounds so let's count
what's the probability of
having
little m offspring
and you can convince yourself that it's
some poisson process
and right now i'm just summing over all
possible outcomes so this obviously is
one
and then this is one
so this is just one complicated way of
writing one is equal to one
so nothing quite happened yet
but we haven't really calculated what we
wanted to calculate which was the
extinction probability
right
so
for the offspring
excuse me
for this allele to become extinct now
all of its offspring
have to become extinct
right
so now we take these m offspring they
live now in different backgrounds and we
say that
the probability
of extinction
of the whole thing
is just given by this expression all of
the offspring
have to become extinct so now we got
ourselves an equation
it depends of course
here
on where exactly
the new clones
what
new backgrounds they have fallen on and
we have to average over that
and
we'll have some model recombination to
tell us
where the recombinant offspring are
going to be distributed in the
distribution
and now we've got ourselves
actually a well-defined equation that
allows us to calculate the extinction
probability and the only thing that
i need to add to this is
i defined as gamma
basically the size
of
this clonal bubble
as
the clone
first grows exponentially
especially if it is
fitter than average that is to say x
positive
but at longer times when the
distribution catches up with it
it collapses
so
the size of this clone is very strongly
dependent
on uh
on the background
right
it's e to the x squared right
so that's actually
why the leading edge of distribution is
so important
it it all
traces to this fact that uh
mutations that fall on the backgrounds
that are much better than ever average
are going to rise to a larger copy
numbers will have
a higher chance
to
spread over
many many other genetic backgrounds
right generate
many offsprings and
and therefore if you like hedge bets
right
not all the
eggs i carried in the same same basket
so
one just proceeds with
his calculation finds
the survival probability and for the
reasons that i just explained the
survival probability increases so
drastically as on move towards
the front
of the distribution
and
in this way
we have succeeded in
defining this probability of
non-extinction probability of survival
so we already talked about
this very general expression
and now this has turned
into an equation that we have to
of course the survival probability
depends on how broad the distribution is
right
we can we have to calculate it as a
function of uh the breadth of the
distribution right so sigma squared
the variance of a distribution when
we're calculating survival probability
is just a parameter right
but now
thanks to fischer's theorem we have a
relation
right so the velocity
speed of adaptation is equal to the
variance now we have an equation that
actually allows us to determine that
variance
that we didn't know to begin with
and the result
is
as
follows
for
large
mutation rates large population sizes
we still have
only logarithmic rate
of
i'm sorry logarithmic
so
the speed of adaptation still only
depends on the logarithm of the
population size
so in that sense
sex and recombination
have failed to completely eliminate
clonal
competition
but the pre-factor of that logarithm
does increase with the frequency of
of recombination
and in fact what one sees is
this
benefit of sex manifests itself in
greater
rate of adaptation
for
a
higher
frequency of recombination
right
even though still a lot of mutations
are wasted
and and i wasted again
you see it right here the survival
probability
is not one
through the whole distribution
it's still only a fraction that
that survive
before in the in the asexual case even
when it even when the rate adaptation
became only logarithmically dependent on
the population size and mutation rate
you could still uh crank it up by
increasing the strength of selection
and here it's actually just
recombinations
s doesn't even matter that much well you
know s matters still because it defines
so the crossover between the two regimes
so
um
forest yeah
this says this says that so you adapt
faster if you just keep increasing the
recombination rate
what's the intuition behind or do you
have a reason why recombination rates
aren't just
really high then
yeah uh so needless to say that this is
only uh
half
epsilon
of uh of the story so i'm talking about
high mutation rate here but strictly
speaking
only talking about
relatively low mutation rates so
compared
to uh
the the the width of the distribution in
the following sense uh so strictly
speaking you're thinking of a
facultative
recombinator
right something like a virus
which doesn't really have to
recombine
to reproduce but will
sometimes
or
like a plant
right which will outcross sometimes but
but not always so
so now
really we're thinking of relatively low
recombination rate and uh your question
is completely valid so having said that
why isn't that
arbitrary uh high right so
good question
one of the things that
immediately comes to mind is
another kind of
interaction right which is epistasis
right so
here we're talking about the
recombination bringing beneficial
alleles
together
onto the same
genome right
but the assumption is that everything is
additive
now suppose you have
genetic interactions
where
okay synergistic uh
genetic interactions right
so
then you'll have a cost
of recombination because you'll start
breaking them up
right so there's something known as out
crossing uh depression or outbreathing
depression right so if you have
two
even uh
sexually propagating populations
that are
reproductive i shouldn't say
reproductive in it
geographically isolated basically
you know fungi growing on the different
stones right and
you bring them together cross them and
you look at the fitness of the offspring
it is systematically lower
than fitness of both of the parents
okay
and the explanation is that
the two populations have
you know fixated or at least have
large fractions of
pairs of alleles which work well with
each other
but not so well
if you're
mix and match between two different
populations right so
things like this immediately kick in so
basically at uh
and you can think of this as a sort of
crossover between selecting on genotypes
or the genomes versus selecting on the
alleles right so
right if we push this
rate of recombination
arbitrarily high or for that matter just
make a genome
an assortment
of tiny little chromosomes which are
continuously getting reshuffled
right
you'll be selecting only on
alleles
right
so you will never allow
these uh
um
sort of epistatic interactions come in
and uh and establish so that's sort of i
guess one way of yeah
i have a question about the other
extreme
so as the
recombination rate goes to zero it seems
that this result does not converge to
the significant result can you comment
on that
yeah
so
um
yeah so
it's a subtlety it's rather interesting
and complicated subtlety so having to do
with the crossover between uh
so
now this curve and the similar version
of this curve
um
that you would calculate for this eye
fisher
technical and subtle
subtle issues so uh so mathematically we
cannot push this calculation
uh
through the limit of rate of
recombination smaller than uh benefit of
a single allele it's a technical little
thing
okay
going the wrong way
so how much time do i have
15 minutes
wait no no minutes yeah
i'm sorry
15 minutes
okay it's like he's got to wrap it up
okay
uh
it's fine it's modular i was going to uh
tell you how
having done
this much of a calculation one can
actually push forward
and
um
understand the
a little bit about uh draft which is
that
other kind of genetic interaction which
somebody here said well was not
so
different joel i think uh
and uh and indeed it isn't the
calculations are
uh really very closely related
so
when we worry about draft we are talking
about
propagation of a given allele
as it hops
from one background to another
and
i was just waxing poetic on that very
subject for 15 minutes
and
it's just that
in order to describe draft
we want to actually
calculate the probability
of
so we're given allele to rise in number
to
any given n as opposed to just the
probability of it going extinct so we
can do that calculation
and the outcome is uh
that you learn something that the
population geneticists and some of the
population geneticists have
realized before
that uh
draft
is uh
really quite
different
from drift i'm sort of realizing that uh
given that i have zero minutes
maybe
i
shouldn't really attempt
to
go into any
any detail except say that
there is a a rather widespread uh
use
of
this notion of effective population size
so the effective population size
is uh this notion that
if you have
this draft
in the population
uh it introduces additional
stochastic if you like force
into dynamics of alleles
which can nevertheless be captured
simply by saying
that
the population
so effective population size is smaller
than
you know the sensor size the number of
individuals in the population right and
this effective sort of smaller
population size size
i'm sorry description of sorry and the
neutral model
with the small effective population size
will then capture
the
dynamics
of
the population with fitness diversity
where alleles hitchhike
and
boost and bust
each other
and the bottom line is uh
that's not so
and that actually has to do with the
um
the statement that i
uh made in reviewing
um
the coalescent and the statistics of
genealogical trees
right
and and i said that the fitness diverse
population has a different statistical
structure of the coalescent
right so if the effective population
size description was valid
it wouldn't be so
it's just the
the height of the tree would get
rescaled but the statistical structure
inside would be the same
and
it's not so
you can actually calculate various
things about it and convince yourself or
rather learn
just exactly
how not so it is
and i was going to tell you a little
more about this
and i
won't and i won't
and i'll just
conclude
so where do we stand
so you know last
uh now 10 20 years
there's definitely been progress
in
understanding
dynamics of natural selection
in these rapidly evolving
uh
fitness diverse
populations
but we're still a little bit in uh
the state of this uh proverbial uh bunch
of uh
blind natural scientists
exploring uh um you know feeling up
uh the elephant
from different sides and so disagreeing
about their experience
from touching the tail or
or
of the trunk there right so
we have i think that was so very visible
in
oscar's talk because
he presented a little model and
immediately there were lots of questions
but
how is this conclusion dependent on
the details
of that particular model and surely that
model
is
not a reality
and
uh and therefore it's irrelevant
then there are all these different
different models
but
what we need
is some sort of a grand unification of
of these models
and we're already beginning to realize
that
many of these
different
models studying different aspects
of
the phenomena
be it you know mueller's ratchet or
adaptation
actually have a lot in common
and uh um
i i think the
the challenge for us
is so to continue
reading
model details
away from
the general phenomena
and
you know this may
sound to you like
another lot of words
but i think there is a
reasonably well defined substance in it
and it goes back to
a discussion of statistical properties
of the coalescent
what we're seeing is
the statistical process
properties of the genealogies have
aspects in common which completely
transcend
the details of of the model
so the genealogy that you will see
in
a population on the
with only deleterious mutations and a
purifying selection
right so that will set up some mutation
selection balance and fitness diverse
distribution and you can ask
what are the proper statistical
properties of the coalescent under these
conditions so these properties are very
similar
to the properties that you will see
in
a continuously adapting population which
just moves forward as as a traveling
wave and if you say that they're both
beneficial mutations and deleterious
mutations
then you can have
a fitness diverse population just
sitting somewhere in the fitness space
and just fluctuating a little bit either
a neuron
and
it will still have essentially the same
statistical properties of of the
coalition so
the details of these models therefore
we can hope
are not terribly important and what we
need
is
to define so back to statistical physics
to define some
equivalent of
the thermodynamic variables and
order parameters some
empirically
measurable
quantities
that will parametrize
the relevant structure of the population
quite independent
of the details of natural selection etc
etc which are setting up the
distribution in the first place
right
because this way we can
actually hope to
make progress
uh just by looking at observations for
example just observe the genealogy
of a population right one can do this by
some extensive
sampling and analysis
let's look at that
figure out what the relevant parameters
are we're not going to learn everything
about every bloody uh polymorphisms
under on the selection
but uh uh perhaps we can learn something
which is even more useful
uh
in practice
such as the ability to
forecast
near future
so
i'm
finished
with this again philosophical
flourish and
pretty much everything that uh i talked
about
um
involved the collaboration uh with uh
richard nair well actually there were
lots of things that i talked about which
didn't involve me at all
and
some of those still involved
richard
so richard used to be at ktp
unfortunately
he has moved on
well
i guess that's a natural course of
events
um so here's mike's plank and tubing
uh
sid goyal uh
is another postdoc
at katp he's actually about to move on
and uh to toronto and uh
unfortunately i didn't really get to
talk about uh
what we've been doing together
uh
uh and adult dayarian is another postdoc
at ktp and uh
together we have this uh little paper on
actually
uh trying to predict
the future based on genealogies but i
had to skip a part of the story and uh
daniel was here yesterday and i'm sure
you've seen him in
action just like in in this picture so
uh
we really enjoy working together on
occasion so
uh thank you very much
squeeze in the questions
so you
mentioned recombination and stimulus
trade-off between
taking advantage of beneficial mutations
and empty spaces
so
if we take the empirically observed
rate of beneficial mutations
and the recombination rates and assume
that the chromosphere is somehow
optimizing for this trade out
so can we get actually getting some
estimation of
the amount of epistasis
in
various genomes
well
so i would have actually very much like
to do
something
something like that
right
so i'm pretty sure
that uh
well actually i'm not sure i know
you can certainly do this in a model
so we can write down some reasonably
well defined model which will have
things that you you just specified
parameterize so fitness landscape by
some suitably defined
epistetic interaction term
and
we can make your favorite assumption
about frequency of beneficial mutations
and
do a calculation and
arrive
at some optimal
um
but i think you want to do more right
you want to actually
try to prove based on existing data
that that is
the case
well i'm not sure we know enough
that
we could actually
falsify
or prove this statement right and i
think the fundamental reason is uh
you know the statistical physics
attitude
is
good for
explaining functional relations
right
and not so good at actually
predicting
numbers
right
so it is much
more plausible
that
we can get
so the correct prediction
about
say dependence of a rate of adaptation
on population size
and perhaps uh you know the pre-factor
of a logarithm can be
you know
a fitting parameter there right but we
can still
test
the functional dependence right
where it comes to trying to predict
that uh
now the frequency of outcrossing of
saccharomyces cervizia
should be x
i'm a little more skeptical just because
it actually requires a
very very
specific precise
knowledge
of
various
parameters having said that
i think if you were to try to do this
in a lab experimental setting
where you have a better chance of
you know controlling selective pressures
on on the east then maybe one can try to
do it
right and
you know there are so various bits of
evidence suggesting that the frequency
of
outcrossing is under selective pressure
you know for example
you know c elegans
right
mostly cells but out crosses with some
small
probability
and
that actually can very easily vary from
one percent to uh you know 50 percent
and uh
i know that people
are
so trying to study
uh
how it depends on the difference
election
selective regimes and for that matter
also the presence of genetic diversity
in the population and i think the
evidence is that it actually is
surprisingly readily
readjusted
right
this is a long
long answer to a short question yeah
actually we've already used up more than
half our break here so uh yeah time to
thank boris